because like for me game boys were the
only game console
or like handheld consoles that i could
actually get every game i wanted
and that's because um every year we you
know visit our family in thailand
and um there's there's always like that
one
store that my my parents would take me
to and it wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't a legit nintendo store
i don't know if you could tell but uh
you basically go in the store
and you didn't they didn't have the game
cartridges they would just have just
just a book yeah
and you'd go for this book and you tell
these people which games you wanted
so like my entire life i would have to
wait like
a [ __ ] like one year to get two games
one was for christmas and one's my
birthday enough like the n64
game boy was like this this this was
like the early steam sale
yeah i would just like the humble bundle
it's free real estate yeah i'll just go
i'll just come come in every year and be
like
[ __ ] i'm about to buy 15 games
for like 10 bucks or something like that
i felt good you don't like the chad like
[ __ ] like i'll take everything from
here to here please
like it was oh i [ __ ] it was such a
good childhood experience just like just
to sit down
and just i would be there for about two
hours and they were like every game
would have a different code
i would fill up this like a4 piece of
paper with just codes
i'm like mother give me all these games
and i wouldn't even play all the games
oh yeah but it just felt good buying
them i felt rich for once it's because
there was so many i don't know what it
was about the game boy advance where it
was like
didn't know there was a game of that but
there is on the game boy advance yeah
like i i used to trade games with the
other kids
oh yeah i did that too yeah just the
games that i was done with like
scooby-doo adventure be like well i i'm
pretty
pretty okay if we're going back to the
lying thing i've i've lied to one of my
friends
so i had this [ __ ] like mickey mouse
game
on game boy advance which i [ __ ]
hated i don't know
i don't know where i'm going i don't
know
i don't know where i got it from i think
i got it from like a cousin's
hand-me-down
or something right but it was like it
was in that bundle of like two or three
like
shitty like not you know not known ip
get why does this exist type of gameboy
advance games that you get
and one of them was this mickey mouse
like [ __ ] platformer game i don't
even remember what the [ __ ] it was but
uh
yeah i was i was in school and my friend
was like oh i got the new uh this is
when emerald came out
right but i had ruby and sapphire at the
time right but i didn't have emerald and
i was like i really want to go
no so i so i was like
so and and his friend my friend wanted
like to play this other like i don't
know if it was a pokemon game or a mario
game or something like one of the main
line games he's like i really want a
place and i said
yeah i got that game
so what i did was i had the thing is i
did have the game
but i didn't want to give it to him yeah
but i had the box for it
no no so i
i did it i [ __ ] i [ __ ] debated him
and i slipped the mickey mouse game
into the barrio boss and i was like here
you go mate in box
don't have to check it now you can check
it when you get home right
and i took the emerald from him and i
still have that emerald cartridge to
this way
did this mom not call you your mom up
he'll like be like what the [ __ ] your
kids scam might i don't know maybe uh
maybe you really like the mickey mouse
game i don't know